I tell me
[Music]
overpowered characters are pretty cool
they're just so fun to watch and I know
a part of you thinks likewise because
those Showcases of power videos have
been some of the most popular and that's
why today I've decided it's time to pay
yet another homage to some of my
favorite overpowered characters as an
additional challenge this time I've
decided to restrict myself to only newer
anime so that means 2022 and Beyond and
that means no Kira Yamato no godsuya no
Kirito no irons none of that Hajime also
barely misses the cut too also this is
gonna be more in line with an opinion
video and a recommendation video because
there's no way we're going to compare
these monsters against each other yep
it's going to be filled with fantasy
anime characters but it's actually not
all isakai surprisingly alright then
let's get going now shall we 2020 was a
good year for overpowered characters
need some proof just look at gin Mori
yeah
2020 was one eventful year and we got no
shortage of overpowered characters new
seasons of mahoka and Sao Ed and we've
got a third guy joining those Cool Kids
on the Block meanwhile we also got the
god of high school fighting craziness in
the form of an over-the-top tournament
Arc Count Me In dinwari the protagonist
is an interesting case he's not exactly
the type of person who wins everything
when you look at it the progression from
the Jin Mori at the start to the guy who
has all those insane moves at the end is
pretty quick and I don't mean to make a
reference to the regrettably Furious
Pace at which this anime has been
adapted I mean when you look at it the
Gin who loses his first fight and the
guy who's going Blow by blow against the
likes of Davey and ilpio at the end look
like completely different people talk
about a glow up of Epic Proportions
however in terms of overpowered
characters Jin does play second fiddle
to appear who's coming up next
[Music]
so among the three big webtoon
adaptations of 2020 Nobles probably got
the least traction of all of them it's
quite a surprise actually considering
it's such a popular title but then again
it's pretty hard to follow both Tower of
God and God of high school so it seems
that not as many people got to enjoy
seeing how overpowered Rye really was
well there's a reason why he's called
The Nobles it's a title reserved for the
strongest amongst the noble vampires you
only have to look at the wiki entry and
look at how much he can do he's pretty
much a noble on steroids in terms of
power he's got a couple of chances to
prove his worth in the series for me one
of the most notable moments was the one
fight against the clan leaders in the
show's finale the moment I enjoyed
enough to include in one of my power
showcase videos in the end though I felt
that having Rye on the list is only
preparing everyone for the next Century
a suspiciously similar character but
this time from Japanese media
foreign
to some I know for all the overpowered
things she can do Maple managed to
remain low-key when it comes to
discourse on these characters it may be
due to how her Feats are relatively tame
compared to the world's shattering
powers of the other characters on this
list or maybe because she gets a pass
because Bovary as a show seems a lot
more easy going and light-hearted that's
truly a strength of the show in that it
doesn't really take itself too seriously
and pretend there's some Grand world
ending Stakes on the loan doesn't change
a thing though Mabel hasn't lost firing
some technicalities where she doesn't
technically win she keeps getting new
powers as the plot progresses but I
think that's the point of the show it's
that kind of innocent chaos which makes
both worry such an enjoyable ride and to
be fair the writers actually try to
balance Maple out a bit by showing that
she can't win everything on her own she
has a lot of close calls admittedly and
maybe that's why she's escaped some
people's Radars especially those who
haven't seen Beaufort when discussing
Opie characters
want to continue with another girl now I
give to you
much like Beaufort slime 300 is a show
that features an airhead female protag
with heavy emphasis on keeping stuff
light-hearted fun and comedic Mayport
stumbles upon skills but in contrast
Azusa does things the old-fashioned way
grinding grinding and grinding until she
reaches the Pinnacle of Power by killing
slimes if the title's not enough of a
giveaway that is who would have ever
thought the diligently farming slimes
will give someone all the power in the
world but here we are with a rather
amusing result slime 300 is a show
that's focused on silly fun which is
mainly why we don't see Azusa flexing
her powers in the way we expected her to
then again being able to come out on top
against everything even when she's not
taking things seriously is nothing to
scoffer unfortunately she does have a
weakness though being productive yeah
bringing all the enemies you can bring
and she'll Breeze through it all having
homework to do you can forget that
foreign
we'll keep the scale low for the next
entry
Luke's an interesting case as an it's a
guy hero he differentiates himself from
the typical one by being a grizzled
hardened assassin in his life on Earth
yeah he's not the playing salary man or
taco type that people have come to
expect from the genre he's someone
chosen by the goddess for his skill in
life with a mission to defeat the
previous hero it would take the best of
the best to accomplish it but while he
doesn't have any extraordinary powers
that would blow people away no big time
flexing to the likes of what we've come
to know from these overpowered
characters though he does use his
experience in life to Great degree yeah
there's some magic in play but at least
he's not the type to use that magic to
drop meteors and such firstly I like
Luke for it assassin Aristocrat as
people have called the show due to its
insanely long name that's one of my
seasonal favorites back then due to how
it slightly subversed the usual issakai
overpowered hero tropes yet doesn't
completely deviate from them to be its
own thing oh and I'm always a sucker for
cool calm and collected Heroes too
total
Sid Gargano is another fan favorite who
prefers to keep himself low-key I
mean keeping himself low-key and
manipulating the World Behind the Scenes
has been Sid's entire gimmick it's his
desire realized in this fantasy world of
his but that doesn't mean that he can't
throw it down if he has to in fact
Eminence in Shadow wastes no time in
showing us how powerful he is and he
really does carry a cool flare to come
along with it from his get up to his
feet Sid is a lot of teenage boys dream
character edgy cool just someone for
teens to admire when he gets put in a
fantasy world forget about it insanely
good fighting skills The Uncanny ability
to be above everything and take
everything in his stride and in case
anyone forgets the guy is literally
Atomic taking nukes to another level and
is nothing short of insane Eminence in
Shadow is a fun watch I admit it's
probably not for everyone if you do fall
in its Target demographic which I do
it's one of the most entertaining shows
to watch in the season
[Music]
atomic
since we're on the topic of 2022 shows I
present to you yosuke shibazaki
watching this part makes me a little sad
for isakai ogisan again it's probably
one of the more unfortunate anime out
there ever since the big delay wave of
2022 it just can't seem to get a break
getting delays left and right which is a
crying Shamy though because its
protagonist is one of the most fun
things to come out of 2022 and as I said
about assassin Aristocrat it's the guy
ojisan also gives the isakai genre a
unique Twist by having yosuke exhibit
his powers in the real world and it's
wild yeah a lot of the shows presented
in recap form seeing as the premise is
about a guy who finished his adventures
in another world from flashbacks we've
seen crazy stuff like him taking down
entire enemy hordes in one blow or the
insane magic that he can do but to see
powers like that being done in real life
flying around freezing people and all of
that it's all good stuff it's the guy
ojisan has been a sleeper hit for me and
his success in my opinion is largely due
to the premise and how the story just
decides to roll with the craziness
foreign
and I'd like to ask for some likes if
you enjoy what you've been seeing so far
it does help the channel grow so go
ahead and take a few seconds to give
yourselves a better YouTube experience
we resume now with Leo demon heart
[Music]
to add to his credentials from the
get-go he's known as the one who
single-handedly defeated the entire
Demon Lord Army however he's since gone
rather quiet and low-key maybe it's
because of how he was betrayed by the
same people he protected those same
people he sought to save from the demons
were the ones who banished him and I'd
have to say that the humans blew it with
him however if there's any doubt if the
former hero who soloed an entire Army is
still inside the new Leo you just have
to look at the fight against the four
generals it's simply a scene where Leo
showcases how Superior he was to all of
them combined but he's also not just
really really good at combat I mean
leading to that point he was pretty much
the demon Army's every man you got to be
strong in other areas too and Leo is one
of the more rounded individuals here I'm
quitting hearing does end with an
interesting twist for its last few
episodes so you might want to check that
show out great plot and you get to see
Leo in action
[Music]
you guessed it it's honor System
ah oh no the poster child for dengeki's
successor to the overpowered hero Throne
there's a reason there's so much
promotional material pairing him with
Kirito and tatsuya however honest
opinion is that he blows the two out of
the water seriously what can arnos not
do the Demon Lord woke up from his
Slumber much like Rye but sees a world
that's gone way beneath his level so
what does he do enter school and waste
no time flexing his powers on some poor
saps imagine being able to destroy
people without a touch only to revive
and do so again and then there's the
jewel against Misha and her super castle
that really stood zero chance the whole
series is simply arnos flexing his power
and everyone being Amazed by it and I
love that it's to the level of parody
like one punch man and if you want to
see a cool protagonist wreck face and do
it in such over-the-top ways and Misfit
of Demon King Academy could be the show
for you it does have a rather engaging
plot hidden underneath all of the
amazing feats so that's a great bonus
for those looking for a show to watch
that's in the same vein as mahoka
foreign
[Music]
comes from a Chinese anime daily life of
the immortal King and if you've got any
passing familiarity with those Chinese
light novels and the cultivation genre
then you already know what you're in for
Wang Ling may appear to be just an
ordinary boy who wanted to be left alone
I mean after going through realm after
realm and stockpiling power it's about a
time he gets a break isn't it yeah this
is a guy who got so tired of growing
stronger too bad only he really knows or
comprehends that as he can't seem to
stay out of trouble and challenges
continue to come knocking on his door in
the anime wangling has some great
showings that in my opinion don't even
do justice to what he's really capable
of what the anime has shown so far is
just a glimpse and there's still a lot
more there in store pretty much the
staple overpowered protagonist in
Chinese web novels and if you decide to
take a dive into the genre it's about
time you know what to expect the title
is no fake out he truly is the immortal
King and one who deserves all the
respect and reverence in the world
us
ually
and that my friend is my list of some of
the most overpowered anime characters
from The Years 2022 to the present
surely there are more of them so it's up
to you to introduce me to them so that's
it for today thank you for watching and
once again I'd love to see you back for
the next one we have a lot more exciting
videos coming up so please stay tuned
see you next time